and maybe I'll start with well we're not
gonna get in a Walter just yet are we
you look scared out of your mind all
right you already already in its brain a
little bit I am high we go on Aaron all
right cool here with Colby rebel that's
a set of real is rebel real it is real
yeah well that's kind of interesting huh
yeah and the profession that you are now
is a psychic medium that's a bit that's
a bit rebellious it isn't just the name
itself right one came what came first
you think you were always a little
rebellious or was or did the name
fulfill itself to you
no actually always more rebellious and
then I legally changed a name to match
yeah Wow perfect okay and where where
did you go out being rebellious I grew
up in South Jersey outside of
Philadelphia I mean there we go I mean
that's about the rebellious part of the
country our people jerks there I mean
that that's the stereotype but but
you're from there you know these people
yeah no I think they're just straight
shooters all right so don't beat around
the bush but I actually think they're
really helpful and honest and I love
going home I love seeing everybody and
it's just a little different like you
know people will offer to just help you
whereas here you know you almost have to
beat someone to get them to talk to you
yeah you got to chase them down and go
yeah you'll walk down the street and
someone won't even acknowledge you here
right where's there they'll look at you
they'll say hello and I really like that
it seems like the Northeast they don't
they don't mess around but if they see
you in a tight spot they will maybe
offer themselves and say are you ok did
you drop your fit you know I'm not in
New York a lot oh yeah yeah in LA it's
like don't here comes a crazy person
don't talk yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
such an attitude of don't talk to me
here yeah it's welcome to LA don't talk
to me yeah when is your birthday
my birthday is 3 to 21 3 2 1 countdown
to me oh wow 321 okay so there's a lot
of things already that I'm feeling with
you like the rebel and three two one so
maybe you just argue is what what
happens March 21st in the
case that has affected you or something
oh it's so crazy too because so 3:21 is
what's called a cusp fire ology you know
I don't do astrology no but I am on the
cusp of Pisces Aries okay so it's you
know that in itself and then it's what
does that mean well I know you said I
know you just said you don't do it but
well yeah I mean a Pisces is very deep
thinking creative like things a little
calmer and Aries is so bossy and
straight board and it's all about them
and are you a little bit of that a
little bit salt really I always say I'm
a I'm a deep thinking Aries and then
it's the spring solstice also we're just
the beginning of spring spring a little
baby new life yeah innings and then just
a time I was born it's kind of something
that I've been told it's three something
in the eleventh house which is super
like whew like yeah yeah so it's so
somewhere along the line I think this
was all destiny I I know the cusp
because of a Beastie Boys song or is it
born what does he say I know you guys
something
a Drock says born on the cusp of
November so that's how I night Google
then I guess trust me but he was he was
you know yeah how our birthdays for you
typically first notice is the worst
birthday podcast and Jonas in general
though they're fantastic and I've
enjoyed most of them goodly okay
abundance yeah and to regret the next
day but really amazing birthdays really
fun stuff do you drink a partake in
substance substances yes I do love a
glass of wine thank you so very my
amazing last that's a beautiful bottle
red wine thank you from this tiny little
island in the middle of the Rhone River
in fourth Florida and
France when you drink some wine to the
psychic medium-- powers enhance do they
get dulled well what happens is actually
you know some people will try to tell
you they get enhanced but that's
actually not true so what happens is
technically your vibration is the
highest when it's in the most pure state
meaning nothing in your system all right
no not even me not even red meat that
was around thing so in the highest thing
but there are a lot of people and I used
to do this too when I for I was doing
this work professionally I'd be at a
party and I'd have a couple glasses of
wine and next thing I knew I'm just
walking up to people and giving them
readings right which I would never
recommend doing what you're not in love
with her I mean there have been all
sorts of stuff right right and but the
reason that is not because I was more in
tune actually it's just that my
inhibitions were lower that's really
what it is so you know that's all it is
is it gives you a little more freedom I
mean that doesn't sound much different
than stand-up comedy you know you ought
you maybe have less ambitions that you
think you're being hilarious
yeah really you're just you're just kind
of your brain isn't telling you hey stop
saying that so yeah it's it's a but but
I always do readings without alcohol in
my system they just they're so much
better they are and me you you you can
you can feel a difference oh yeah
absolutely yeah okay but I'll tell you
though so if I do a full day of reading
to teach long days of workshops nothing
is more relaxing than a glass of wine
worse because now it lowers my vibration
that allows me to feel a little human
for a future few hours well it's it's
kind of like if ignorance is bliss the
opposite of that is if you're fully
aware it must be exhausting it can be
but I mean I love what I do super lucky
you're really lucky but it absolutely
can be because you're tapping into
everybody's stuff Wow
it's like a whole frequency plus if
there's loved ones on the other side I'm
really tapping into
everything I'm sorry that you have to
tap into Breton and Aaron's here because
they're probably my stuff is good what
we and we will get into we just so you
know ladies and gentlemen we are going
to do a reading later where we're just
going to attempt to maybe have some fun
and let you you work your vibrations I'm
sure I'm saying it exactly the wrong way
I'm sorry I don't even know how to say
it properly no it's perfect but first as
someone who is who is rebellious is born
on the cusp I want to hear what your
worst birthday was on March 21st yeah
and it was a bad one oh good I love when
people say they feel pain I'm like good
let's hear about it Wow okay so birthday
is March 21st
it was my 21st birthday don't they call
that something um golden yeah no it's a
there is a name for it but I don't know
the name of it maybe your listeners will
will chime in they can always email us
at Michael at Michael Kosta calm and
tell us what that is
so it was it's I was turning 21 and so
very excited I was going to college at
the University of Florida big party here
we go yeah I'm feeling the vibration huh
you know it definitely had a reputation
and so I got to go out legally sure you
know obviously you know you're in
college so there's all kinds of ways to
go out beforehand but yeah I got to go
out legally and I was so excited and I
put my my sexiest dress on Oh
tell me about I know it could have been
the zipper dressing here I mean I I
honestly can't believe I used to wear
this thing but I swear it was like a
spandex tank top I know I know it had a
zipper right up all the way up the front
like up the front who does it yeah I'm
telling you this yeah this was cutting
edge for yes time yeah yeah and I bought
the frenzy was - oh that's great it's
true story yeah and I can't see called
me right now she's wearing a zipper
dresses and and brand-new shoes my
boyfriend had got me and I love them
there were high heels I was excited and
so you know we went out and went to this
club and
and obviously I was drinking because I
got to turn 21 and what does Kolby rebel
maybe it's not even rebel at that point
but what is called a drink on her 21st
you know I I don't remember at that time
it probably either was something really
sugary and Rudy probably or like a
captain morgans and Diet Coke because
that was really big back in the day so
one of those two got it um and and maybe
I was doing a shot or two in between I'm
not sure I really don't remember but I
you know I was really having fun I was
having a great time but I dunno so I had
a boyfriend and we've been gone out many
years up to that point so you're 21 so
how many years is in many years I
started dating in when I was 16 16
uh-huh so that would be silly as well
and yeah what's right school again you
guys decided to go to college together
kinda I mean he went to college and I
followed okay guy I did that codependent
thing yes okay I feel like women these
days think that's like a sign of
weakness like that's okay people follow
people for relationships it's okay I
gave it my best shot
yeah and so we having a great time now I
guess if I'm going to be fair sure I may
have been dancing on a table or two hi
I'm not sure but I do know he was
getting very upset and wanted me to stop
being so risque I would guess that you
were as as the college girls I've seen
that where's the progress is everyone I
guess he probably thinks so um so he got
upset yeah and then he wanted to leave
sure that's my 21st birthday I listen
yeah even if I was obnoxious or
upsetting it's my 21st birthday you need
to suck it up yeah right yep I mean ya
really need to whatever your issues are
you need to just hold off and you can
discuss them the next day
yeah but he didn't they said we brought
it up so anyhow it's a tough at the time
yeah you know and he's young too he's
young too and you're getting a lot of
attention and it's not you know it's not
to him he's drunk
- yeah I'm not here defend this guy but
I'm just saying like what about yeah
yeah yeah so we we go to leave and what
was the club name do you remember I do
not for the life of me but we go and I
was so mad at him and again I was drunk
but I was so mad at him and I and he's
like get in the car and I'm like I'm not
getting in the car getting driving with
you right and they seen
well I from New Jersey yeah I'm turning
I'm chunk I would imagine there's a bit
of a scene I'm imagine some people are
looking at you guys hey yeah yeah yeah
and so I took off these gorgeous shoes
yeah and I was like and you take your
shoes and I threw them through the
passenger window at Humber good and I
just started walking down he was a kid
in the classic I'm not getting in the
car and so we ended up leaving me and I
was out he did because there is a lot of
times you go to a club or a young
person's bar club you will usually see a
woman walking barefoot in a scar behind
them slowly following like that in the
car he did but he ended up leaving so
what happened is now I'm walking
barefoot in my zipper dress um hot I
Hale it was a scene I guess and and so
after a bit though this girl starts
driving by and she slows down and she's
like you know do you need a ride and you
know obviously this is the day you do
not I mean in a college town you do not
take rides from strangers
don't you even all chopped up in a
basement somewhere but I took the ride
yeah he is a woman too but you never
know I mean a woman as his fare it could
be bait you know right right but I took
the ride so she drove me got a hearse
where's your wallet did you do have a
wallet I mean this is a tight dress I
know but you can you can see what my
brain is thinking about but I really
remember yeah um but so she drove me
home and that was that
and what you know and then this person
that I am I stayed together for many
more years actually yeah okay but um
here's another quick little point though
so full circle so weird
interesting a full circle yeah so
there's all of that and this many years
later just about a month or so ago I'm
in New Jersey and I just gotten done a
long night of working doing readings
true and it was just turning into my
family's place and sure enough if I
don't see this lady
washer this true story in a black dress
also her high heels are in her hand
she's crying okay and I knew she needed
a ride sure I knew because I had I could
reveal everything she was feeling and I
had been there and I just stopped my car
yeah and I said do you need a ride yeah
and I offered her a ride there we go
and it was so it was so full sir yeah
yeah I mean if you go down Santa Monica
Boulevard on a Saturday night you're
going to find you're going to find
people but I could have made I could I
could have done my karma a lot quicker I
guess well I mean it actually wouldn't
be a bad apple in your hand yeah we will
give you a ride home
high heels and tiers high heels and
tiers is yeah just that's going to be my
next project so guys what what
eventually ended it with you in this guy
what was the cause um just a few odd
things I mean time had gone on we
weren't engaged and you know we really
weren't the best fit and a wonderful
person and and but we really weren't the
best fit and so it just kind of ended up
maybe just kind of coming to that point
yeah but you know it's so weird to I
hadn't seen him in so many years and I
just randomly ran into him the other day
as odd as it is weird yeah I would like
to know what his recollection of this
21st Oh would have been amazing I'm
pretty sure he probably wouldn't
wouldn't talk about me you know I love
him to death be so conservative he's so
conservative or at least as I had would
have remembered him what
when did used to
art this was 21 was there any indication
in your brain or heart that you could
read people at this age oh I was I mean
I don't had this gift since I was 4 4
years old yep yes my grandfather came to
me and and what does that mean you bruh
grandfather came no he was he had
crossed over and will - paradise they
got it thank you
just because I'm not I'm you got to talk
to me like I'm a third grader he's dead
yeah definitely did not breathing okay
thank you
we call it not in the physical world got
it okay and so my mom had put me my
sister to bed we shared a room and so he
came standing next to my bed and had a
conversation with me and then said get
out of bed and go tell mama tell my mom
what he had said so I did yep and she
was like who told you that no he said
grandpa I mean yeah that was her love
tale right and what she's like him
where's grandpa
and I says oh he's in the room mommy
yeah and what I didn't know because we
were really young that he had passed
away about a week before that well my
family didn't believe in telling
children really yeah they didn't know if
we could handle it
that is always tricky but here you are
talk about here so that was like the
first thing but yeah by 21 this was
where I didn't understand what I was
doing yeah yeah so I was running around
giving reading walking up to people even
this boyfriend I mean there were things
I knew and way before I did this work he
would say man you must be psychic or
something like I mean it was crazy or I
would call someone right when they were
dialing me I mean it was just so much
like that weird okay call me and let me
play skeptic for a second sure because I
because I have to as stand-up comic yeah
yeah sometimes it you just it's a
coincidence are you arguing that a
coincidence is not a coincidence but I
mean the other day I text um I called
somebody and they were like I was just
getting ready to text you is that the
psychic world occurring or is that just
that's the way life is well I guess for
me I don't believe in coincidences you
don't okay now I think coincidences are
synchronicity okay now does that mean
it's psychic no but you're
intuition on some level or the other
person so the intuition and what we all
have intuition I mean that's we all have
it you know fight or flight right and so
on some level it was just your intuition
kicking game yeah psychic is when you
combine the logic with it maybe you're
gonna go you'll think of someone and
then literally in that minute they call
you that's more psychic right that's not
intuition got it okay now the other
thing too I'm going to be really fair
and honest these days you know I've been
I had left a whole other career I was a
tax manager for a CPA for oh my god
luring alert yeah well and and so I did
that well there's a there's actually a
better career before that that I'll
share in a second place for me to do
this it did seem really crazy and really
weird and you know I do know that
there's something about it it's crazy
and weird now could it mean could it be
just telepathic could I just somehow be
connecting to someone's thought mmm-hmm
I mean I can't say no it doesn't feel
that way because sometimes there's
things I know that I just no way I could
know right but I'm total I don't know
the answer yet until I'm passed and then
I'll be able to go okay this is what's
up yeah but so I'm open to that I think
I think someone who is skeptic is it's
okay as long as they're open to the
process of like okay maybe it's possible
like because anything is possible
sure I mean this is this is the argument
for atheism it's like you know being an
agnostic and caustic is more like I
don't think it's this but I don't really
know but I'm open as an atheistic oh
that absolutely is no God and it's like
well you know you got you always got to
be open yeah well why don't I just don't
understand that or cynic right this
gives like there's just no way this is
possible sure the point is is you're
really pigeonholing yourself and you
believe that because god forbid you die
and then there's someone at that pearly
gate you're really going to have a
moment of regret
sure why not believe sure and then it
you cross over and there's nothing there
you can say I told you so yeah I mean I
could argue against that but but that's
not what we're here to do we're not here
to argue Colby and I I find it
fascinating that you've made this your
profession what was what was the job
before the tax manager I was a
professional wrestler yes I really was
top three jobs ha our professional
wrestler tax manager and now a psychic
yeah yeah but the psychic medium has
always been there I just didn't realize
I was supposed to do it with my life
right
what was your professional wrestling
name hammer and Heather steel yeah what
would happen if we googled hammer and
Heather's you would see a ton of videos
no shell everywhere what is it hammer
and Heather steel yeah H a mm e RI again
we'll have two together and then steel
ste le I bet you I could even spell it
wrong and Google would in my um now
Colby I met you at this comedy show
where I was performing stand-up comedy
and you were also but we don't call it a
performance you were reading
yes age though right I was on stage it's
a demonstration we followed up a medium
demonstration demonstrate or psychic
demonstration and the show ladies and
gentlemen is in Los Angeles and it's at
tail waggers
in hollywood hollywood and it's called
two girls one pup show and it was really
fun and you bring your dog and you
perform if you have a dog and I brought
my dog Walter my dog Walter's here now
come here buddy and he's been he's been
a good dog huh just been sitting here
say hi to the camera he's very confused
he's been on my facebook live many times
I think I'm just gonna put him on the
table
oh you can't you can't tell me no one
Ron err Aaron sit down buddy okay so you
briefly introduced yourself to him at
the show but I thought it would be fun
cause you also can feel vibrations from
from animals yeah absolutely because
animals have souls
they have so if it has a soul you can
tap into it so does that mean a turtle
and a lizard and an ant you can you can
kind of I mean those are tough I know
but not to get too crazy and we would
you can get crazy in Willow I think you
can tap into plants energy of anything
old-world I mean like I'm not kidding
I'm not laughing at you I'm laughing at
the SD I officially are calling a
butterfly into my hand and it did whoa
now with the turtle and all that things
yeah tell us about it is the validation
meaning sure you know like with Walter
I'll be able to read Walter and you can
validate sure we're not looking for
Walter to validate well yeah he doesn't
even know what names if it's a turtle
lizard you know is it possible yet it
just may be a little harder sure then
yeah we don't know if I mean I can
probably tell you what an instinct and
you know keep working dude yes I really
into it Walter well feel free if you
know I don't want to force anybody to do
anything but if you're feeling anything
from Walter you know feel free do you
want me to be quiet do you want me to
ask you questions do you want me just to
you know I don't you tell me what the
best way to kind of well how about we
make it a little interactive girl what
I'll do is I'll just give you the things
I'm getting yeah you can connect to her
to resonate on behalf of Walter sure
then you just give me some yeses or no
things like that that sounds fair enough
to you that sounds great and I in again
you know you already met him so but but
that was just such a chaotic fun
environment and you were kind of going
through all of these animals and it was
really it was really funny are you able
to see Walter on there there we go good
boy Walter okay it's that we got I'm
like you can cut me out we have
beautiful Colby and we have weird Walter
okay so what are you getting what do you
or like an I can try to validate some
stuff for you well this is really good
it's um all right here we go buddy
you're good just just hang just hang put
out put out a lot of your vibration okay
so a couple of things that I am getting
is feeling where you know Walter is what
we call an old soul alright so what
happens is it's kind of like not that
real puppy puppy fever it's a little bit
more like I've been here I'm actually
here more for you that sort of thing and
it also he gives me this feeling where
he could have been an emotional support
dog it would have been a great emotional
support dog if he had done that but he
also gets through
this weird thing where I feel like he's
got these nervous habits because he
makes me feel like he gets a little
nervous yeah and there's something I
don't know if he doesn't like grass
under his paws or something huh
but there's something where he can be a
little sensitive that's all he shits on
on concrete which maybe maybe that's you
know and and we don't you know one thing
that I would love to get your read on or
take on is he is an adopted dog he we we
named him Walter because we felt like
you know he besides looking a little bit
old with his face but he just kind of
carries himself like an old man a little
bit yeah but here he is wanting to bite
my fingers what just is weird having
somebody get into your brain and read
your vibrations huh so but we don't know
his backstory and I know everyone in LA
wants another dog's backstory but I
would be curious what you're reading my
mind facing you yeah my feeling is he
feel that he was left alone a lot
actually
so I feel like if he's in real big
crowds or something he may get a little
anxious you know practice and cry that's
because he he makes me feel like he was
very isolated prior to yeah prior to you
guys having him which is sad well the
thing though is so he's got a little
PSTD I feel like he gets a little
reactive about things yeah but what's
also interesting he gives me this
feeling of feeling much more happy and
content with this family but it took a
while for him to trust that's the weird
thing like I feel like he had you guys
had to earn that trust with hell yeah
you got it right now as well and he
makes me feel like he really enjoys
being in the car like I just feel like
you must take them everywhere else a car
because he makes me feel any also likes
the ocean because I just saw water and
the breeze so I know he really really
likes the ocean the beach okay his
favorite place yeah when you say you see
the ocean what does that mean what are
you actually seeing are you seeing
ideation I just saw drive up the coast
so I don't know if you were recently on
like PCH or something like that but I
saw me there go nice job and I saw along
the the ocean and what I
so I just feel like he loves kind of
hanging out and doing it and he also
gives me this feeling
he just doesn't feel like a big player
like again I think he's real much more
happy around people than he is other
animals no he just makes me feel like
he's kind of a people dog he he is his
people dog meaning you know the people
that he's grown accustomed to
he loves yes he's shy in big groups like
you said ocean you nailed it I mean this
[ __ ] dog I think he's a fish yeah he
loves the beloved sand yeah I just don't
think he likes grass that much well pay
attention to see it runs on grass our
earthly roles in grass I just don't
think he does it yeah but I would see I
don't know is that is that this is a
here's me you know I agree with you he
doesn't yeah okay like grass that much
he likes concrete but is that because
he's a city dog or is that because he
you know is is that because he doesn't
like grass because the mercury was in
retrograde or whatever um no no no I
think he just doesn't um okay yeah good
boy Walter he's just going to hang right
here when you when you can when you can
kind of see or tell me how you said you
speak to people who on the other side do
you speak to them and you see them I
hear them or see them or feel them so
what happens is when someone's on the
other side like you just kind of get a
feeling around you get a feeling around
someone like and it's not it's not super
overwhelming all the time sometimes it's
just a subtle no subtle feeling do you
really mean and it'll be like this
person like Rhett this person likes red
apples or is it like fruit or is it like
food it just ah you don't know goodness
it depends on the spirit I'm more super
visual or very very specific somewhere a
little more general yep some don't like
to talk a whole lot some do it people in
life they're no different
yep it's really no different and how can
a boyfriend lie to you if you can feel
the vibe well to be honest it's like I
know this is
going to be a little TMI but it's why I
haven't been on a date in three years
because you can figure out what the hell
you know it's so crazy and it's it's um
you do know and I've always known and I
can like just check in and it is what it
is okay
it is what it is Walter what else do we
want to know about you now his first
birthday uh-huh we weren't there we
don't know where he was born
we don't know are you picking anything
up no but one thing the only thing I'm
seeing see I'm seeing again because he's
not going to show me he's going to know
what state he's in or what right so he's
from his point of view what I'm seeing
is him just stuck in a room is what it
makes me feel like Dawson and the room
feels pretty plain oh no it just I just
feel like and so so he's not going to
show me the rest of the house because he
wasn't in the rest of the house yeah he
wasn't running through a yard he makes
me feel like he was just closed off in a
room man I I we don't know how we can't
validate that but it but but it feels
that would be sad and I'll tell you one
thing just makes me feel like he really
enjoys like when you hold him like
especially maybe even around the ribs
and all yeah it's like he makes me feel
like he loves the sense of security of
that see how calm he is when you do that
the other thing is when you hold him
like a baby I know I mean oh no I'm
really look at this ah look at that
should pop a breast out in heaven
physical on my on my breast look how
sweet he is though do you think yeah I
do see he's shy around lots of people
but if you hold him like a baby it's
crazy yeah that's crazy
yeah Kolby he likes to feel safe though
that's that's what it is so right so he
would have been good bundled up like
bundled in blankets he likes he just
likes the feel but that really to me
tells me he really likes that because he
didn't have security as a puppy and I
just it just yeah but you know it's your
thing bro feels like you know he's so
happy yeah he is happy we think he's
happy
we can't validate all of this stuff but
as a dog owner who's adopted there's
probably a lot of people out he's
chewing on my sunglasses as a lot of
people out there
who
adopt dogs you don't know their history
and it's fun to hear someone it offers
some perspective and it makes sense and
you know what helps I mean you know
because I've done this a lot yeah well
people will bring their animals to my
space for a pet reading jur and it
really is fun I really love it because I
love animals so much but what's great is
sometimes they'll come to me and dot say
listen we've got a little bit of this
issue happening right and I'll be able
to kind of tune in to see what's
creating it or why and what is around it
that they can do to try to help kind of
resolve or to solve the issue at hand
what is your space where is the best
space for you to kind of feel vibrations
well I literally just moved okay I'm in
Westwood so I have a band is Westwood I
have a brand white office the actual
office space is there do you do you hang
certain things or is it just comfortable
for you you know I think I'm so lucky
that I really had this gift for so long
that I can literally tap in any where I
am and I just make that if I just kind
of open up my awareness yes I can be
anywhere and just be able to tune in no
matter what so for that I'm really
grateful that's great yeah I just you
know and I think again when you're
passionate about what you're doing and
love it I didn't know you know yeah and
it does it you know I think too it helps
people it helps people it helps animals
it really does it makes it surprisingly
makes a difference we need answers in
life as humans we want and we seek out
answers and you can be a skeptic about
this you can believe in it you can be
somewhere in the middle it's always
beneficial to hear someone else's
perspective and in an answer may click
you know and may go yes that is what it
is this is a birthday podcast so we'll
finish with a birthday okay what is a
great birthday you've had that you've
that you if you can remember one you
said you've had mostly great mostly good
birthdays but is the one that comes to
mind that was really really one you know
one that was thank you one that was
really wonderful it was
i xl okay Wow I didn't even know she was
40 gentlemen yes and I went to Whistler
Canada it's beautiful up there and it
was what was nice as I had gone for the
new year that year yeah so and then my
birthday was in March so I had such a
great time I went back right and when I
went back all of the people that were at
the clubs and restaurants they all
really remembered my name
that's nice and so when I went up and I
told him it was my birthday they called
me by name oh it was so friendly I felt
so welcomed and by your name you mean
hammer and Heather steel that's
obviously what I meant
of course isn't it amazing it's like the
cheers song you know where everybody
knows your name
it just is nice when people remember
your name it is yes it's really you know
and just when people say you helped you
helped it's nice oh yes
Colby rebel you guys psychic medium
where can everybody find out more
information about you if they go to
psychic rebel calm they can book a
session with you and if they want a pet
session they just have to book the
session and then put in the email that
they want it to be a pet that you want
to be going to be here yeah that's it
yes well it's really fun talking to you
I enjoyed I enjoyed what you did at the
show I'm sure that must have been hard
because there were so many people and
animals around a lot of energy up it's a
tough but it's also beautiful because it
get again it's like it's really fun I
mean look at this I got to meet Walter I
got to be Walter here we got to learn
about his weird grass thing maybe that's
why he always shits on concrete you're
not crazy
it you'll even start on grass and finish
on concrete why do you guys want to hear
about the way my dog ship sand beach
beach is where he really wishes he could
live I'll have to share the news to my
girlfriend that it's sad that he was
probably born in a home in a broom never
even well it feels like it yeah it just
it doesn't feel like he was Roman open
land by any means but that's why but
that's why I like you know when he's
feeling good and he's feeling safe like
you can you can see it in his face yeah
you can see like this wonderment he
still has it it's like this what pay
attention to his eyes he's got this like
wonderment when he's like
running he's like this is crazy but I
love it thank you for sharing yeah thank
you for sharing this you guys check out
all the rebel you have officially used
your certificate there we go I
appreciate you giving that to me I won a
raffle and thanks for being on the
podcast oh I'm going on decide the best
time and thank you so so much
cool coley rebel thank you very much
yeah